[Musique]
merci de nous accorder quelques minutes
pour répondre à quelques questions pour
commencer j'aimerais savoir pourquoi
c'est important pour vous d'être ici on
voit beaucoup de ministres la défense du
monde entier de responsables militaires
pourquoi pour un responsable de la croix
rouge c'est important d'être sur ce
genre d'événement c'est important parce
qu'on rencontre quand même passablement
de personnes que nous avons des
dialogues nous avons des activités dans
leur pays de les rencontrer de bien
comprendre d'où ils viennent quelles
sont leurs univers d' analyse aussi la
situation internationale est extrêmement
important et c'est comme toujours ces
événements ces plateformes
7 comme une caisse de résonance qui joue
une autre musique dépendant que si on
parlait on entend la musique à moscou à
berlin à washington aux nations unies ou
en afrique
je pense il est important pour une
organisation comme la nôtre qui est très
liée à l'action sur les lignes de front
de bien comprendre les réflexions
stratégiques en arrière et je pense est
une excellente occasion justement pour
un pourra entre s'entretenir avec des
leaders politiques des ministres de la
défense des chefs des chefs d'armée qui
sont quand même au coeur de l'action
aussi du cicr le respect du droit
international humanitaire l'engagement
pour ce respect est donc une excellente
occasion pour en parler et justement en
quoi c'est donc une réunion à moscou est
elle différente d'une réunion à berlin
washington justement il est clair que la
tonalité est différente les analyses
sont différentes si on regarde et j'ai
attentivement suivi ce matin dans la
première réunion un peu les priorités
que
les personnes intervenant ont mis en
avant ses priorités et l'ordre de
priorité n'est pas partout le même le
jugement sur les autres n'est pas pas
partout le même
et je pense en tant que organisation
neutre impartial et indépendant il est
tellement important qu'on connaisse les
différentes perspectives des
belligérants
on ne doit pas être d'un côté ou de
l'autre
il faut être de tous les côtés
comprendre les raisonnements de tous les
côtés pour trouver cet espace qui très
franchement est souvent de plus en plus
restreints dans les théâtres de conflit
mais qui est un espace qui est définie
par ses différentes perspectives et donc
il est clair on entend ici parler du
nucléaire du changement climatique du
terrorisme des mesures qu'on prend sur
ses activités d'une manière un peu
différente on entend parler d'une
manière différente des états unis et des
européens ici à moscou que si je vais à
bruxelles à londres ou à washington où
on entend parler différemment de moscou
et de ses activités pour encore une fois
pour une réalisation neutre et impartial
il est important de connaître les
raisonnements des deux côtés pour bien
savoir où l espace neutre dans lesquels
on peut bouger
j'aimerais maintenant revenir avec vous
sur vous avait parlé de théâtre de
conflits sur certains d'entre eux en
particulier le yémen cela fait plusieurs
années que malheureusement ce conflit à
court et mais ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois on entend peut-être un
petit peu moins parler quelle est la
situation sur place
à l'heure actuelle la situation reste
assez dramatique point de vue
humanitaire n'est ce pas et même si
peut-être l'intensité des activités
militaires dans l'ensemble du pays non
ce ne sont plus deux tels qu'on les a
vus peut-être y encore il ya deux ou
trois ans il en reste pas moins que des
activités militaires continuent il ya
quand même une grande bataille autour de
marie qui est considéré comme
stratégique par les différentes parties
au conflit et may need
est ce ce combat et ses combats ont
quand même continuer à avoir un effet
direct sur les déplacements des
populations sur l' empire mans en
général la situation humanitaire
comme vous le savez le yémen est
peut-être le pays le plus fragile dans
la région dans lesquelles il y avait
maintenant tant d années d activité
militaire et donc une société
extrêmement fragilisée dans lesquelles
il est difficile de trouver des portes
sortie parce que l'accès pose problème
l'approvisionnement du pays et le
redémarrage de l'économie du pays pose
problème et donc tous ces problèmes
qu'on a créé et qui ont été créées par
les combats des dernières années sont
quand même toujours la haye trouve une
solution difficile donc une des raisons
de multiples raisons pour lesquelles
j'entends visiter le yémen à partir la
semaine prochaine pour faire le point de
nouveaux est aussi pour alerter la
communauté internationale a comme vous
l'avez dit à juste titre
au fait que le yémen est un peu passée
en 2e ou 3e catégorie d'attention de la
communauté internationale autres
théâtres de conflits un conflit dans
lequel la russie a pris par la syrie
avec ses immenses déplacements de
personnes
quelle est la situation alors maintenant
il y à la situation des déplacés au
centre la syrie mais aussi dans les pays
frontaliers comme au liban qui accueille
des centaines de milliers de personnes
vous parliez de difficultés d'accès au
yémen c'est également le cas en syrie
n'est ce pas un peu moins dans ce sens
parce que nous avons quand même réussi
dans la plupart du territoire syrien en
nous engageant avec le gouvernement
syrien mais aussi avec d'autres parties
au conflit d'avoir des accès à part le
nord ouest la province d'idlib
on couvre quand même une surface assez
importante la syrie reste l'opération la
plus importante du cicr cela dit comme
je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure il ya
beaucoup plus à faire et nous avons
quand même vu ces derniers mois cette
convergence d'impact de la guerre qui
dure est quand même pendant dix ans
l'impact du coït 19 l'impact des
sanctions l'impact l'implosion
économique du liban que tous ces
facteurs ont mené à un appauvrissement
de la population syrienne qui nous
préoccupe fortement aujourd'hui on
estime que peut être plus de 80% de la
population syrienne qui est encore en
syrie sous et vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
donc qu'on est en train d'accumuler les
problèmes alors que les problèmes sont
guère résolu vous avez juste titre à
évoquer le destin de ceux qui ont quitté
le pays mais aussi le dessin qui sont de
ceux qui sont déplacés à l'intérieur du
pays et pour le moment faute de solution
politique on ne voit pas très bien
comment ceux qui ont été déplacés
pourraient regagner leurs foyers
dans un dans un avenir prochain il y
aura certainement ceux à l'intérieur du
pays qui devront faire le premier pas et
donc nous sommes quand même très très
concernés et nous espérons que peut-être
cette ces discussions de superpuissance
qu'on a vu se déployer à genève vont
nous amener peut-être vers une certaine
convergence et vers une considération et
une situation politique un peu plus
favorable pour traiter des grandes
difficultés économiques de société
d'impact conflit avec la sur lesquels la
population syrienne souffre aujourd'hui
juste pour revenir sur la syrie c'est
vrai que un dialogue au plus haut niveau
et une convergence entre les grandes
puissances on pense bien sûr à la russie
et aux etats-unis donc serait
serait la bienvenue pour pour la
reconstruction du pays et pour qu'il y
ait un retour un retour des réfugiés
mais concrètement comment faire puisque
dans ce pays on manque de tout les
infrastructures sont sont en lambeaux
comment accueillir de nouveau la
population si si justement on manque de
tout concrètement quels seront les
preuves les premières étapes à
entreprendre
il ya différentes anglais n'est ce pas
il ya certainement un angle important
politiques à prendre et vous savez bien
que les nations unies et et le processus
d'astana sont quand même lié pour
trouver au niveau du comité
constitutionnel des solutions qui peut
être donne une certaine confiance aussi
à ceux qui ont été déplacés de revenir
je pense c'est un sujet important et
cela ne passe pas sans penser à
peut-être à des solutions vraiment
politique de notre côté en point de vue
humanitaire
je pense qu'ils nous sentons le plus
important parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de syriens aujourd'hui qui nous
approchent en milliers pour retrouver
leur leurs proches qui sont disparus qui
sont dans les prisons qui sont de
l'autre côté de ligne de front je pense
il est extrêmement important que le cicr
ait accès à ces populations
emprisonné que nous ayons une
coopération des deux toutes les parties
sur les personnes qui ont été dites et
qui sont disparus je pense il est
important que nous puissions aussi
stabiliser la situation point de vue
infrastructures le cicr a fait des
propositions correspondante surtout sur
la stabilisation du système d'eau du
système d'électricité des services de
santé je pense sans un minimum de
volonté aussi de la communauté
internationale de contribué à cette
stabilisation ça va être extrêmement
difficile de prévenir une situation qui
s'empire et se dégrade davantage mais je
pense nous on est quand même là sur les
lignes de front et on a fait des
propositions correspondante et on espère
que comme vous l'avez évoqué cette
convergence
peut-être peut-être convergence entre
les grandes puissances font donner en un
pic à 1 ap et us une dynamique à une
aide plus substantiel est peut-être une
transformation politique aussi plus
importante
vous l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à
l'heure la question du coc vide cette
pandémie que nous traversons depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire
la solidarité internationale affichée a
du mal à se transformer en actes
concrets on pense par exemple à l'accès
à la vaccination dans les pays les plus
pauvres
quelles seraient les solutions à mettre
en oeuvre pour qu'un maximum de gens à
travers le monde puisse avoir accès à la
vaccination
il ya certainement une solution première
c'est de produire plus de vaccins et je
pense pour le moment le grand problème
reste il n'y a pas suffisamment de
vaccins qui sont produits après il faut
une distribution équitable des vaccins
l' open comme à juste titre vous
l'évoquez la communauté internationale
peine les les systèmes qui ont été mis
en place soit bilatéralement soit
multilatéralement par kovacs sont pas
encore suffisamment efficace mais
j'aimerais quand même de nos expériences
sur les lignes de front aussi dans les
contextes les plus difficiles j'aimerais
évoquer qu'il faut beaucoup plus que
juste un vaccin et une volonté il faut
des systèmes des systèmes de santé qui
sont capables à vacciner il faut des des
chaînes de froid pour préserver les
vaccins il faut un personnel qui est en
très entraînés il faut une organisation
qu'il le faut je pense on est tous là
pour contribuer pour jouer un rôle
important le cicr et la croix rouge
internationale dans son ensemble avec la
fédération on travaille pour élargir les
capacités de vaccination pour soutenir
les états dans leurs stratégies pour
penser aux plus marginalisés et plus
pauvres parce qu'on sait que les vaccins
doivent arriver
c'est à leur porte aussi on travaille à
mettre le dispositif logistique en place
on travaille à négocier des axes et
surtout du côté cicr dans l'est dans des
endroits les plus pauvres et les plus
difficilement accessibles ou peut-être
des groupes armés contrôlent et les
états n'ont pas de pouvoir donc vous
voyez qui a toute une complexité pour
mettre en place un système qui va enfin
augmenter les chiffres qui sont
scandaleux pour le moment n'est ce pas
c'est le 2 % au maximum de vaccins qui
arrivent dans les pays les plus pauvres
donc il faut renverser cette balance
mais de renverser cette balance est
d'avoir une solution plus équitable va
être extrêmement difficile et n'oublions
pas que le corps était seulement un
vaccin nous avons et nous sommes très
perturbé à noter que dans beaucoup de
pays les programmes de vaccination
réguliers ont été coupées parce qu'il
n'y a plus de ressources parce toutes
les ressources mandant la vaccination
qu'ovide donc je voulais juste illustrer
un peu avec ces quelques exemples
combien complexe et la situation
actuelle et combien il faut travailler
encore pour arié peut-être en 2022 2023
et 24 à une résolution de cette
situation très insatisfaisante à un
niveau plus global
est-ce que la levée des brevets peut
être une solution ou bien ça reste
marginal par rapport à ce que vous
évoquez le système de santé qui a tout
autour et qui lui est plus important
oh moi je pense que ce que je viens
d'évoquer de renforcer les systèmes de
santé de renforcer les productions ça ça
reste peut être l'aspect clé après sur
la question de la levée des brevets
on est tous d'accord c'est une question
aussi philosophique et politique et l
importance que vous de donner à cette
question elle peut changer d'une
perspective à l'autre on est on est même
pas au sein la croix rouge
internationale on n'a même pas
nécessairement exactement les mêmes avis
je propose aussi qu'on soit un peu crus
plus granulaire dans nos réflexions et
qu'on regarde région par région
situation par situation ce qu'il en faut
dans certains contextes une levée de
brevet peut peut être être le catalyseur
qui lance un processus bienvenue dans
d'autres ce n'est pas tellement le cas
nous avons vu aussi dans les discussions
sur la levée de brevets combien elle est
complexe parce que la première fois en
tant que président du cni serge discute
à l'organisation mondiale du commerce
et on voit combien les situations les
négociations sont interconnectés et
combien toutes ces questions sont
complexes cela ne devrait pas nous nous
prévenir de nous attaquer à ces
questions et je trouve toujours la
meilleure chose c'est que chacun fait ce
qu'il sait mieux faire et je voulais
certainement un mettre en relief combien
nous nous engageons pour renforcer les
systèmes de santé pour négocier les
accès auprès des populations pauvres
nous sommes dans impliqué beaucoup dans
dans les prisons dans les camps de
réfugiés dans les situations de
déplacement on travaille avec les gens
handicapés avec les des favoris dans les
sociétés notre souci premier est
vraiment de mettre en place un système
qui puisse aussi arriver à vacciner ces
gens qui souvent sont oubliés par les
stratégies nationales et qui sont encore
plus oubliés par la communauté
internationale et et leur politique
monsieur maurer merci de nous avoir
accordé cette interview
[Musique]